so with the Islam fight
up to that point the rule was that if
you beat somebody who's ranked higher
than you then you take their spot
like uh pound for pounds especially and
then Islam beat you but you kept the
number one pound-for-pound spot yeah and
and that's I don't think there's a
person in the world that disagrees with
that yeah you know like you weren't
fighting in your weight class you came
up a lot of bigger guys so you kept
number one pound per pound can you
explain what pound for pounds okay let's
let's get into that so when you say uh
in pound for pound you take someone you
majority of the time you will take take
it but at the end of the day that's
always going to be a
different to an actual uh like a
ranking like a featherweight ranking
right for featherweight ranking you beat
someone you take their spot you just
beat the guy that makes make sense we
pounds a pound that has a lot more than
just
just your ranking in that division so
it's gonna it's gonna come down to skill
power for pound like we understand that
so if you we were all the same size yeah
with the same skill so everything was
even playing Phil except for the skill
like you had your skill and uh whatever
it was but we're all the same size like
who would sort of win so say imagine me
in a heavyweights body with uh the
heavyweight strength and all that type
of stuff you know what I mean like so
that like you know what would I do to
these heavyweights you know that's how
people would uh look at it type thing so
it's a weird one it's obviously that's
why a lot of people just can't stand the
power for pound rankings but everyone
loves talking about it it's a big deal
I'll be honest with you being a champion
was great being pound for pound uh
number one which uh Jon Jones just took
that for oh he did
I don't think we've all of them I don't
think we've all of them but I mean I
think with the UFC yes I I
actually I was dying to know that and I
and I resisted that
yeah
I'm glad Jon Jones won I'm impressed by
his victory but I just don't think we
saw enough in that fight to go ahead and
compound for pound number one yeah but I
mean you're gonna
I guess it's gonna have to do with he he
actually he said it said it really well
where it goes by what you've done lately
as well right it's going to go with that
you know you you might have done a whole
heap four years ago that's got nothing
to do with now you are not powerful
power we don't know what you're doing
right now so that that's always still
going to come into play though
you know again you're right it was just
that one but what he did moving up he at
least he moved up and showed that the
powerful pound comes into play you know
uh the body of work that we've done in
the last three years obviously a lot of
people are going to be look what Alex
has done in the last few years and you
can get that but at the same time look
at what John Jones has done as well so
can I really argue that when you look at
you he's going to be one of the greatest
of all times so for him to take that as
like hey yeah what do you do what do you
think about his fight I mean were you
just like what the [__] I expected uh
him to Oh I thought he should wrestle I
I thought if he was to grab hold him I
think he's going to have do really well
if he uses all these tools I think his
biggest the biggest problem for him
would be with these heavyweights landing
on him but when it comes to wrestling I
think he's going to outdo all of all the
heavy weights even your steepes I think
uh because Jon Jones wrestling is
incredible like you know and that's a
people are really
I don't think it's underestimate I think
people know but I mean look what even uh
DC was taking DC down you know what I
mean so it's pretty crazy uh to see uh
what he's capable of but I didn't expect
him to be so aggressive with the
wrestling that surprised me so because
uh we chatted to him in the lead up to
that that fight and he was uh you know
saying that he's seen holes in the stand
up and I'm like is he really gonna try
and uh exploit that or is he gonna do
what he should do and go there but it
was always he just got right in there as
soon as he found that right time to
clinch and even when he went down and
shot he made sure he was sticking he's
like I ain't giving this guy a chance
which I thought was a very clever and if
I knew that he was going to be in their
positions I would have expected a finish
I just didn't think he would be that
aggressive uh to look for a finisher to
look for the control I thought he might
like play play try and clinch grab a
hold and then look for a trip or work
him on the cage and maybe look for a
takedown from there
um so yeah it was a it was still a
little bit different to what I expected
just purely because I didn't expect him
to be so aggressive with wrestling right
give him pound for pound number one that
is kind of like me saying we should
punish him for making it look so easy
so maybe he does deserve it yeah but uh
actually as I said I talked to John Jazz
we talked to him uh on uh UFC fight week
with Robert Whittaker we're having a
chat to him and like that question come
up where uh they asked if they're like
you know if you win do you think your
number one power for power while I was
sitting right there and he goes look it
goes by and that's when he touched on me
being active and what I've done look
what I've done that my body of work so
right now is like because I'm not
chasing power for pound I'm trading I'm
chasing the greatest of all time and
things are obviously that's what I'm
chasing but
um look at the body of work he's done
because he's been fine I've still got a
couple more years to do that so I'm
going to keep uh pushing for that but
right now you know powerful pound was uh
where I was at which is a great
accomplishment and I I still look to to
get that back anyway so it motivates me
motivates me to be like all right I want
to get back in there whereas jira rig is
in July bang and then do that rematch
with Islam and you know and then
obviously like I said 2023 is going to
be a a massive year for me do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude